third time's a charm at least that's
what the creator of mighty number nine
is probably telling himself keiji
inafune a spiritual successor to the
Mega Man series has been delayed for a
third time inna foon a made the
announcement in an update to Kickstarter
backers today that developer concept
encountered critical issues in the games
online matchmaking unicorn a said in
preparation for the februari release of
mighty number 9 we've been working hard
with our partners to resolve any network
issues and porting work necessary to
publish mighty number 9 on the various
platforms however the issues relating to
the network modes were more critical
than expected and it has become apparent
that we will need to delay the game from
its februari 9th release date this also
marks the second time the game has been
delayed due to online and matchmaking
issues a new release date for the game
has not been announced but according to
Enoch khooneh it should still launch
sometime in spring 2016 he went on to
say for this third delay of the game we
have no excuses for disappointing our
fans and especially our backers once
more we want to take this chance to
express our sincerest apologies to
everyone who has looked forward to the
release mighty number nine was
originally slated to launch in 2015
before being pushed to februari 9 2016
it's set for release on ps4 xbox one and
Wii U with both physical and digital
versions it'll be available as a digital
only game on xbox 360 playstation 3 and
pc playstation vita and the nintendo 3ds
versions are in the works but release
dates for these versions have not been
provided yet when we do find out mighty
number nines release date you'll hear
about it first on gamespot
you